thanks for having me
okay so
very quick
what do you do
i'm starting consultancy and work on
climate finance and how
africans nigerians can assess more
climate finance so i'm an activist i'm a
researcher
and yeah that's about what i do
[Music]
i won't ask you how old you are but for
a young person who i mean you have the
world ahead of you why would you take up
activism
um i was fascinated about the
environment when i was younger the
colors of lizard is so colorful it's so
beautiful sometimes but i was also sad
when i went to niger delta potakota and
saw how where all the money nigeria has
came from
and
you just saw such
underdevelopment in such areas so it's
really sad when i go to the beach and
the beach is normal there alpha beach so
it's
it's sad
so someone has to talk about it how can
we encourage other young people to get
involved i mean to look at how to
encourage
the larger society to buy into
this climate change matter and other
environmental issues
we are the ones going to face the
impact of climate change we are the
younger ones so where we should be
included in all the decision making
processes which be included in all the
stakeholder engagements so that we have
our voice we can because it's it's
easier with social media coming up
everybody shares things it's easier to
follow up on what is happening you
you've traveled around the world almost
around there you were recently in
germany and so in other countries what
did you go to do in germany i went there
as a climate witness to speak about
climate change migration we have a lot
of activists in germany that are working
towards
short and coal
factories and industries so they brought
us there me and another person
from the philippines to talk about how
climate change impact us how we have
felt climate change so that they can
have sympathy and they can know what
their emission is causing in the other
parts of the continent did you think
that any anything you said there made
any sense no it made a lot of impact
because some studies some g7 studies say
that germany the g7 countries um
contribute about 50 to emissions
historical emissions so we can say they
are responsible for climate change so
they should take up their responsibility
and help other countries that they're
still trying to develop we had our
government talk about coal as a source
of generating power
is there anything we can do to
i don't encourage that it's not a good
idea for nigeria to go into core but i'm
positive and positive after the
climate change conference morocco the
government of nigeria met with the
government of morocco in nigeria and i
think there are a lot of partnerships in
the way for solar
energy and for renewable energy there's
also a world of
renewable energy in the northeast so
there's a lot of things on the ground
and we're hoping with good advisors and
with um
with focus purpose and
the interest of the people at heart
our leaders will make the right choices
and right decisions they've done well
and we hope they continue
doing better
thank you
[Music]